ce 19 décembre 2023 restera comme une
date sombre dans l'histoire de la
République un projet de loi sur
l'immigration inspiré du programme
historique de l'extrême droite et de
Jean-Marie Le Pen a été adopté par le
Parlement grâce aux voix du
rassemblement national car malgré vos
éléments de langage les chiffres sont
têtus c'est bien les 88 votes pour du
rassemblement national qui vous permett
d'obtenir une majorité sur ce texte de
la honte la minorité présidenti avaent
fixé des lignes rouges elles ont toutes
été allègrement transgressé et ce sont
désormais les lignes bleu marine qui
sont franchies vous avez t cidé les
amendements les articles et surtout
votre honneur cette loi d'armanin le
Penti est une infamme loi de police des
étrangers elle demeurera comme le moment
où le mandat d'Emmanuel Macron s vé dans
le
dshonneur 2017 et en 2022 nous avons uni
nos voix contre le rassemblement
national pour faire élire Emmanuel
Macron ce temps est désormais révolu
puisque le gouvernement en est désormais
le porte-voix le président du barrage
républicain est devenu celui du naufrage
républicain ce texte a fracturé votre
camp mais aussi le contrat social qui
fonde notre République aujourd'hui j'ai
honte pour vous vous collègues qui comme
moi sont issus de l'immigration et qui
ont mêlé leur voix à l'extrême droite
vous avez permis l'adoption de ce texte
si ce texte était en vigueur à l'arrivée
de vos parents ou de vos grands-parents
vous ne seriez pas ici en ce triste jour
je pense aussi et surtout à nos
concitoyens enfants d'étranger qui ont
bénéficié d'êtes social qui leur ont
permis d'étudier sereinement à l'école
de la République à ceux qui ont pe
bénéficié a automatiquement de la
nationalité française grâce au droit du
sol qui fait l'honneur de pays pour tous
ces gens-là nous dénoncerons ce texte au
Conseil constitutionnel et nous
lutterons contre vos
ID je
remercie la parole est à Monsieur éc
Dupont
Moretti garde des saau et ministre de la
Justice merci'
PL merci madame la Présidente il régnait
jusqu'à ce il rgnait jusqu'à ce moment
une ambiance assez tranquille et je
voudrais et je voudrais pouvoir et je
voudrais pouvoir vous répondre d'abord
la déchéance de de nationalité monsieur
le député elle est dans le Code civil
c'est Monsieur François Hollande Seror
de ma
part deuxièmement voyez-vous vous êtes
tombé dans le piège du rassemblement
national qui crie victoire mais
voyez-vous une victoire en réalité c'est
lorsqu'on a livré un combat alors je
vais vous rappeler deux ou trois choses
très simples
très très simple d'abord dans ce texte
le RN n'a pas ajouté une virgule et pas
un mot au Sénat il vote contre le
texte devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée
nationale silence contre le texte en CMP
il ne propose rien à l'Assemblée
national dans l'hémicycle c'est avec
vous qu'il vote monsieur le député et
avec
qu'est-ce que ça donne au final ça donne
que madame la Présidente Le
Pen vote enfin le texte alors que son
premier ministre autoproclamé dit qu'il
ne le votera pas première crise dans
votre
[Musique]
gouvernement c'est un compte de Noël qui
nous est raconté à vaincre sans péril on
triomphe sans gloire ça n'est pas une
victoire c'est la plus grande escroquer
de
l'année je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre